Presentation. And we will now move on to the budget workshop for Solid
Waste Management.
Okay, thank you.
Good afternoon, everyone. Mark Wolffolk, Solid Waste
Department. Six months in. I just wanted to put that cat out there
so you all go easy on me today, all right?
Also want to thank our staff for getting me to this point.
I just mentioned, been here six months, but everybody's been
working together. The Synergy has been great, but I
just want to go ahead and throw another caveat out there on this presentation
today. You're dealing with two rookies, right? So I'm
here. I'm also flanked by our assistant director.
How many months has it been? Two months.
Two months? Yeah. Assistant director, wealthy, white.
So congratulations to her.
She's still hanging. Okay, so we'll go ahead and
just get into the budget presentation.
Apologize. I kind of broke the traditional format that
you all follow, but I do want to concentrate on the budget portion.
So if we could go to the next slide.
I just wanted to give you all an overview of our executive leadership team here.
I think the key takeaway from this slide is that we have
about 427 positions in
the department. And the
other key takeaway from this slide is and I mentioned earlier how the team has
been working with Synergy. Our deputy director,
Anthony Booy, that's here today. I like to recognize him.
This will be his last budget presentation. Go around with us. After 42
plus years, he's getting ready to retire. So definitely like
to recognize Mr. Anthony Booy for his contribution.
So we've got some big shoes to fill there. So next
slide, please. The demographic data.
Just wanted to give you just a little quick overview of that. Of course,
77% of that department is African American,
followed by Hispanic,
Latino, and then white and Asian. But to me,
the biggest takeaway of this is the diversity, gender diversity that we
have in the department and the amount of women that we have that are
doing the jobs today in solid waste management. So I
just really wanted to focus on that. That 29% to 30% really
caught my eye when I arrived to the city. And I think there's
just more good works to come. Next slide.
Just why do we have to have solid waste department? For these three reasons.
Right here you have the Solid Waste Disposal Act of 1965,
as well as the Texas Health and Safety Code, and of course,
the city code and ordinances. And of course, without effective
solid waste management, our neighborhoods would be overrun by all
types of vermin and really have deplorable conditions
in the neighborhood. Next slide.
You're all familiar with the forward facing departments that we have or forward facing
business units that we have. So I won't spend much time there, except for on
the last yellow highlighted area there.
In addition to all of the services that we provide on a weekly,
monthly or bimonthly basis. We also focus hard
on those other support services such as homeless encampment
abatement program, the litter abatement program, as well as
many of the council district service funds and keeping those programs going
as well. Next slide. Okay,
just a functional review of our organizational chart.
You'll see where basically we have three different
sections in the department. It's either going to be north operations,
south Operations, or Administration. And whatever doesn't
fall in there will also fall under our maintenance category.
But as you can see, the estimated total for this FY 23
year will be about $95.6 million.
All right, next slide, please. At this point, I'd like
to turn this point of the presentation over to our CFO, Ms. Wealthy White.
Thank you, Director. The solid waste department
revenues are generated through two funds the general
fund and the recycling revenue fund.
The General Fund revenues includes fees from
our dumpster permits, our extra capacity container
program, our nonresidential garbage and our
container lease fee and some other small accounts.
The Recycling Revenue Fund is generated from the sale of recyclable
materials like glass, scrap metal,
batteries, electronics which are sold by the City.
Also included in this fund are fees from our
tire recycling and our business recycling programs.
On this slide, we see a projected 3%
increase in General Fund revenues due to the annual
CPI and prior year revenue activity
to be realized in fiscal year 2023.
There is no projected increase in the Recycling
Revenue Fund, and with these revenue funds, we have
a total budget revenue budget of $14.8 million.
Next slide, please. Our expenditures
by funds are our department,
our collection programs and other service delivery
components. Includes our garbage collection,
tree waste, heavy trash depositories,
curbside recycling, drive through recycling
facilities, sponsorships. All these
areas are supported by the General Fund. And the fiscal
year 2023 proposed budget is $95.6
million, which represents a 1% increase
from the current fiscal year.
The Recycling Revenue Fund proposed expenditure
supports the City's recycling programs, related services
and recycling education. The proposed budget
for fiscal year 2023 is $4.1 million
and it represents a 5% increase from
fiscal year 2022. Next slide,
please.
Looking at go ahead.
Yeah, they're ahead. You can go ahead and explain if you can back up one
slide to the pie chart. Thank you. The projected
budget by fund for fiscal year 2023 in the General Fund budget,
personnel represents 41% of the total budget.
nonpersonal accounts for 59% of
the proposed budget, and within that 59%
services are 23%. And restricted
accounts, supplies, non, capital transfer and debt
make up the balance of 36%.
In the Recycling Revenue Fund, the percentage for
personnel is ten point 57 and nonpersonal
is 89%. The next slide
shows the net change in the General Fund.
Next slide, please. Thank you.
At the start of fiscal year 2022,
the Solid Waste Management Department began with a budget of $89
million and with adjustments throughout
the year, it increased the budget to 95,
601, 576. Looking forward
to the fiscal year 2023 General Fund budget.
Additional adjustments were made to include contractual
and mandated adjustments resulting in a proposed
budget of $95,610,939,
which is again a net change of approximately
1% from the current year's budget.
Next slide. All right.
Thank you, Ms. White. Now with this FY 23
proposed budget, we do expect some impacts and a lot of those impacts
are going to come just by growth and demand, increasing growth in
demand throughout the city. We also expect
some of those impacts to be attributed to the vacancy rates that we currently
have that we're working on driving down overtime,
as well as temporary services that we'll use to mitigate some of the shortfalls
that we incur throughout the year.
Operational program subsidies will be another area that we think will also
impact. And that's just from observation of being here a little more
than six months. Meaning that we may at times have
some a need to supplement our services by calling in help
from some of our private counterparts in the industry that will be
in the areas of heavy trash collection which we're about to embark upon right now,
as well as curbside recycling. And then
again, we have challenges with addressing some of the neighborhood density projects that
are going on and some of the inflationary contracts
that we're seeing or inflationary impact to contracts that we're seeing today.
Next slide.
Okay, again, FY 22 accomplishments.
There have been several that have been going on prior to my arrival
and then since my arrival, they've continued to
keep the momentum going. I think the biggest takeaway throughout
the year has been the fact that the city has gotten aggressive and they recognize
the fact that we've had a shortage in some of our key or critical
positions, that being the driving positions. And the
$3,000 sign in bonus was great for a while,
but now we're recognizing the fact that everybody else has
gotten hip to the game. So we've got to continuously
think of something new and innovative to recruit and attract more talent.
So Mayor Turner actually, and as well as some of the council members here,
have been instrumental in kind of helping us develop CDL training
programs that we're currently working on right now. And then we're
also actively, still actively recruiting licensed
CDL drivers, but we've also got a pay increase on the way for them
as well. So hopefully that will continue to attract more qualified
talent in this area. Next slide.
Some of the FY 23 goals. Again I think the biggest goal that
we have that you'll hear me constantly say is we want to reduce
our dependency on the general fund. Meaning that we want to become a
more sustainable department in the way that we, we manage our
department, the way that we manage our resources and again become more
solvent in that process. We want to diversify the revenue streams
I know there's a lot of talk about the city of Houston not
having a residential rate and then that is the case too.
We would love to continue working on that and there's some other opportunities as
well to diversify the revenue streams as well
as it involves working in the commercial
sector or offering our services to some of the commercial programs that
may be out there throughout the city. We also
plan to reduce our vacancy rate. We're currently hovering around 17% right now,
department wide, maybe about 15% for our critical vacancies.
Again, working with Mayor Turner, adjusting the
starting salary that should be taking place within the next couple of
days. We noticed that we think we'll be a little bit more competitive
with our counterparts in the private industry and get our starting
rate up closer to $22, $23 an hour.
And then we really want to work on standardizing our routes too.
And a lot of this has to do with the growth. And that's a good
thing. The growth that the city of Houston has incurred over the last
decade. And it's time for the solid waste department to catch up with
that growth right now so that we can continue our quest and accomplish
our goals as far as delivering on time services concerned.
Next slide.
It's just a little graph and some studies that we've been doing again
with the long cities or the department's long range plan that's been out
there. Just a couple of facts over the last ten years.
I believe we see now the population of the city of Houston being about 6.6
million. To us, that represents about 20,000
additional households that we're still servicing with the same level
of organizational support that we had ten years ago.
And again about a 300 or 225 ton increase on
a daily basis that we're still responsible for collecting. So we
definitely feel the strain. Now the bottom, the other arrows may seem a little bit
confusing because we have it pointing down, but it says 2% increase.
The reason I did that is because again, the city has
grown exponentially in those ten years and the department has not kept
up with that growth and that's why we're experiencing such
challenges with service delays, probably a less than a
1% increase and no increase in the size of the fleet.
You'll hear me constantly say we got to invest in our greatest
assets, employees and equipment. Without those two,
we can't deliver that service. Next slide. I'm sorry,
can you hold that slide for a second? The top
of the chart, the line graph, just kind of illustrates
that relationship that you have. Most cities
our size has when it comes down to full time employees,
to number of households served. And you'll see the
blue line, which represents our FTEs,
normally should be above that orange line. As far as
households serve, you want to keep that relationship.
Houston is at the end. You see there's a big disparity there when it
comes down to our counterparts. Next slide.
And that concludes our presentation. Happy to
answer any questions that anyone may have. Thank you, Director. First question
comes from Council member Abby Cayman. Thanks, Chair.
First Director.
Thank you. And please relay our appreciation to everyone
in the department, especially our drivers that are out in the field.
Are they still working six days a week right now?
Yes, we're still at six days a week, hopefully not much longer.
Yeah, and I know I've seen some drivers out there.
We all work late, but not as late as they do. We're not up as
early as they are. So please relay my gratitude to them
really quickly. I wanted to check in because we talked about
the increase in multifamily and looking
at additional needs towards the future.
I had passed, with the support of council last fiscal year, a budget amendment
that was going to direct the department by the end of fiscal year 22 to
start the stakeholder engagement process. So we can be looking at
mandatory multifamily recycling, whether the city takes on that burden or
not, just requires private, but where
are we in that process and has that begun yet? Yes, and that's a
good question. I'm happy to report that process is going, it is ongoing.
I believe the team started that prior to my arrival
and since then, now we are to the point where we are meeting biweekly
and when I say we, I'm talking about members of the Apartment
Association and other industrial
and commercial businesses throughout town that represents those
areas. Perfect, because as we talk about future needs, and I know many of
us around the Horseshoe bring this up as to you,
the life cycle of our landfills and if we do not start
curbing waste now, we're going to be in big trouble. So I
thank you for that update. And in terms of the profitability
of recycling materials right now, are we seeing an improvement in
that? Yes, there's been a slight improvement in there. I think
our CFO can attest to that as well. In fact, I don't
believe we have to pay our processor now. Is that correct? Yeah.
So the way our contract is set up is
that when the materials, the blended value of the materials
reaches a certain threshold that the city doesn't have to pay.
Right. And just one follow up on that and then I'll go back in the
queue. There was an effort to educate
on the contamination of recyclable materials.
Are we seeing an improvement in that? Yes, we are.
And we're currently working with our processor right now to find out what that new
rate is. When I arrived, I believe our contamination rate
was around 39%. We're going to be doing another
evaluation within the next couple of weeks, in the next
week or two, and we expect that rate to be down. Terrific. We're already seeing
indications fantastic. And if I could go back in queue, please make sure
council Member Amy Pick. Thank you, Mayor Pertem. And thank you,
Director. First, I want to thank you for the work that you're doing,
especially in District Day. We've seen a huge improvement in collections
since you've been on board. And when we were meeting
about using our service funds to supplement the work,
your question was you weren't just, of course we'll take
your money. You were really questioning, well, why are we not picking it up on
time? And I really appreciated how you were thinking about that.
So my question is about the business recycling program and
the commercial collections. Have those two programs
been evaluated recently to see if it's beneficial to
continue that financially or if that's something
we should suspend or increase or has that been evaluated?
Yes, and we're currently working with some partners
here. When I say partners, I mean these are big partners, ExxonMobil and
whatnot. So we have the small
scale recycling, commercial recycling program for the small producers and
small businesses. And that seems to be working relatively well right now. We know
that there are some opportunities for improvement, and we're working on addressing
that right now. But perhaps I think the biggest takeaway is
that a lot of the partners that
want to work with us right now, they see the value in that program.
They appreciate the fact that we've gotten started and they're ready to
help us take it to the next level. So abandoning it
would not be the right choice at this time. And as far as
the commercial collections for trash pickup, is that something that has been
evaluated, too, where commercial businesses can
basically contract with the city for a pickup? That's something that I'm evaluating
right now. I still need to spend some time with our revenue and finance team,
but I do see some serious potentials in there.
Okay, thank you. We can't keep giving away the business.
Council Member Sally Alcorn.
Thank you, Chair, and thank you, director,
for your presentation. You're operating
according to the solid waste, long range solid waste plan
at a $20 to $40 million deficit.
Correct. Just walking in the door. $20 to $40 million
down, we're picking up 391,000
homes. Correct. We've got another 50,000
on sponsorship that are paying their own private trash.
Correct. I really appreciated your slide that
had the different cities on there. I would add that
those cities that you have on those
slides, especially Dallas, San Antonio and Austin, all have a fee.
The fee in Dallas
is $34.30.
Weekly garbage and recycling, monthly brush and bulky bulk waste.
Austin has pay as you throw ranges from twenty two
dollars and sixty five cents to forty nine dollars and fifty cents a
month. San Antonio, $14 through
they also have pays. You throw through $26.
It's employees and it's equipment. And I don't
see how you get there with $96 million a year
from the general fund. So I'd like you to
give me your experience in Tampa and any other
experience you have with how a fee was originated
and how you think that might play out here. Absolutely,
sure. In Tampa, as well as other enterprise
fund departments in the solid waste industry,
fee was a little bit higher in Tamps, around $36 per household.
But that fee was also covering the cost
of the service. So employees and
equipment first supplies the other associated
expenses that come along with managing a solid waste program.
People often forget about the true cost of disposal.
Those are real dollars. So when we show up at a disposal
facility at a landfill and we have to drive across someone's scales,
there's no sort of internal fund transfer that satisfies
that transaction. There's a check that they're looking for and that disposal
cost usually cost about a third of the service. And if
I was going to rank it, I would probably rank it somewhere between number
one and three. When it comes down to the assets,
it's going to be right there. Between the cost of employees and the cost of
equipment are the three greatest costs
of that service. So again, that's what your rate is designed to cover.
In Tampa, we also had a different disposal system,
so we had a bond to cover. So our rate was designed to cover the
cost of satisfying the bond each year.
However, once we reached the areas and the bonds matured and we
paid that bond off, we enjoyed a $14 million swing.
Really, it's about a $28 million swing. All of that money
did not stay in the department. We can't show a profit.
We cover our reserves, rainy day funds
and whatnot. The rest of that has to go back to the general fund in
order to support other areas of the city. So whenever
you hear me talk about a rate or bringing on a rate,
it's number one to take care of what we need to take care of in
house so that we can deliver the on time service and have the equipment that
we need so that our men and women can show up and
deliver that and not have to stay out until eight or 09:00
at night or come in on a Sunday. But it's to cover that
first and then support the other areas of the city that need it second.
And when you talk about the city of Houston, we got a lot of work
to do, right. So if we were to embark upon that road,
it's going to be a couple of years before we start seeing the benefits of
that return. But the goal would be, again, as I mentioned earlier,
to reduce our dependency on the general fund and
allow those funds to be used for other areas throughout
the city. I told Council Member Pat I
was offended when she sat across from me and said that she wanted to
run her solid waste programs like, well, what are we?
And I know Houston has gotten away with it, but I think with the
times and conditions and the way things are today,
we've got to find some way to offset that, and I think our residents and
customers deserve better. Council Member
Carolyn Evan Shabbaz. Thank you, Mayor Protem. And thank you,
director. I don't know if you ever settled. I know we talked about living
in district d, but at any rate,
I'm just curious. We talked before about hot teams
and how only some districts have to
employ people for hot teams. In my particular
district, we employ four people and
pay for two trucks. And I think we talked about how that cost could
possibly be absorbed because it
does take out of our districts, whereas there are others
that don't have to pay those costs. So I didn't see anything
in the budget regarding that, and so I'm encouraged that
there's still an opportunity. So maybe you can address
that in terms of making that a little bit more equitable. Thank you.
And to make sure I understand your question, are you talking about being able
to cover the cost of what the hot teams are providing or expenses
associated with all districts? I don't think all
the districts have them. There are those that do, but there are all
districts. Do you have one? A hot team? No.
Okay. No. We're talking about
solid waste right now. So I'm not trying to compare what each person
pays, but my question is we have to hire four.
I have in my case, we are four men or
women, and we pay for two trucks for trash
pickup. And I'm just wondering because you and I
had the conversation not trying to say that others don't pay for
other things, that I may pay for something that you may not, but somewhat
it just doesn't somewhat seem equitable for
some districts to have to pay for hot teams and employ
additional people to pick up that which all
Houstonians expect. Right. And so if you could address
that, I'd appreciate it. Absolutely. And I think what we may be seeing
is it may speak to trying
to find the right way to say this, the difference in neighborhoods
throughout the city of Houston, as large as it is. You have
some neighborhoods where we see development occurring,
and as that development is occurring, we notice the amount of illegal
dumping and the needs for hot teams will
kind of draw down. In other districts.
They may have a few more commercial areas than residential
areas, so their approach may be a little bit different. It may be
a quarterly approach or something of that nature. But what we're
seeing and what I'm observing is that each district has
its own unique features, and one
district may require a hot team. And we appreciate the hot
teams because they kind of fill in the gap right now where
we want to, but we just can't because we're trying to address the more
pressing issues. And I think that's why you may see
that from as I travel throughout and I look at some of the neighborhoods and
I see where there is a greater need for some of
those areas. And I think the wonderful thing that I've learned about City of
Houston, I was kind of kicking myself because I wish I would have met with
them on the first day that I was here is the Mayor's Office of
Innovation and Sustainability. They've got some wonderful
ideas. And we were chatting the other day about now
that we know where a majority of our debris is being generated at
what kind of programs, how can we augment our programs so that we
can concentrate our equipment in those areas and not
as heavy on the areas where there is not as much generation
of the illegal dumping and whatnot? And I think that's why a lot of
times you'll see that difference. Right. I do understand that it's a
difference, but we had talked about it, and I didn't know if you were
able to do that, which we talked about, but apparently not
at this juncture, not at this time. But we're still working on it. We haven't
forgot about that request. Thank you. And in fact, I'm going to
address something in your district pretty soon.
Vice chair, Ed Pollard.
Chatty Cathy over there. Thank you, Chair, and thank you,
Director, for your presentation. A couple of
things. One, if we were
to have a fee, what would be some
of the priority areas of your department that
would see an impact from that fee from
the jump? Would it be additional drivers? Would it be pay
for additional equipment? Like, where would that money go towards?
Right. So when you say from the jump for us, from the jump means
at least a year out with the
time that's required to secure equipment
and the shortages and the backlogs and
what it takes to secure that equipment, you're talking
about a good year, a year and a half out. So what
you would see right off the bat is on time service. So you put
your recycling container out on Monday, and that's your schedule collection
day. It's collected by Monday at 05:00. Okay, thank you.
And also, I just want to give you a shout out for being real open
minded about the District J Private Trash Day and working with
our office to collaborate on ways in which to make that program efficient.
It's something that we're continuing and that the constituents seem to
find beneficial. So thank you again. Look forward to continuing
working with you. Thank you,
Director. Wilfred, I must say, you've done a bang up job in your initial time
here. I used to always tell everybody, I love me some Harry Hayes.
I'll always love me some Harry Hayes. But you've done a great
job coming in and picking up what Harry Hayes started developing.
I hate to see Mr. Anthony Bowie retiring.
And I see Ms. Carolyn out there. They did a
great job for us many, many times,
and especially in 2017, when I had the
blessing and the honor of working with, I think, one of your counterparts.
He actually did a stint in Temp in Tampa. Mr.
Mccreck, Kerry, and David ran solid waste in
San Antonio at the time. And Jessica and I spent literally 40
days in a row with them, never missing a day. And he and
I would talk about various things. And one of the things that struck me is
he was telling me that you all had a waste energy plant
in Tampa and you would sell the waste to the energy
electric company and they would move the waste into
electricity. Is there any option for us here in the city
to do something similar to what you did in Tampa? I would love
it. It is an expensive undertaker,
I tell you, but it is definitely a way
to save space, and it eliminates the need for
the landfills. That's the biggest value right there.
So, idea wise, how much does it cost?
Today, you're probably looking at about a billion dollars.
Yeah. The last one that I know of that was permitted in South
Florida was about 880,000,000. And that was about three or four
years ago. Okay. And another quick question. Years ago,
we made a lot of money on commodities.
The commodity market was a lot different. How is it today? I know that
I'm literally thinking maybe six, seven years ago, we were making a
good deal of money on commodities and then went south on us, and then we
started paying waste management to take our
commodities. Is there any coming back in that market I haven't really looked
at? Yeah, it's kind of leveled out, but we're still not seeing what you all
enjoyed during that time ago. In fact, from Florida,
I used to look at that and I used to catch heat because people would
say, how come you're not doing what Texas is doing? But again, it's a
regional market. It's very volatile.
I definitely wouldn't bet my life savings
on it. But right now, we're kind of breaking even in
that recycling market as far as the commodities are concerned. Thank you,
Director Bowie. We'll miss you. You've done a great
job for us, for you. And so have you, director Wright. Even though you're not
going anywhere, we're not letting you. Council member Robert Gallegos.
Thank you, Mayor Pro TEM. Thank you, Director, for the presentation.
It was enjoyed visiting with you last week
in regards to getting some updates,
I know that leaving my office right now.
Constituent services pointed out to me that we have a constituent that
has been waiting for a trash can, because I believe their trash can
was stolen, and they've been waiting for a. Trash can since April.
I know that we have some trash cans that
are sitting on Capitol Street that they're still been waiting for
that trash to be picked up. And I say all this because
I want you to elaborate what's happening in regards
to trucks breaking down, the lack of hiring employees.
That way the general public can hear exactly what
the issues are because all
they see is that they want their can and the can is not being delivered.
Right. All they're seeing is that they want their trash can picked up and their
trash hasn't been delivered until they call our office and we try to
explain to them what the situation is. If we're leaning
towards a fee, we need to let the
public know why. So if you can elaborate
what the issues are, please. Yeah, and there's several
compounding issues and I think we also want to be clear to
say that the fee gets us going in the
right direction. It's not the magic elixir.
So what people may be experiencing when they
run into those delays is, again, we're dealing with
420 some odd employees department wide.
That's not enough. 645 sq mi.
645 sq mi. Exactly. So what
you see the team doing is concentrating on the big
fires and trying to keep those from growing even larger.
So if somebody's waiting on a can, it could very well be because
another team member was reassigned to take care of a route
and that may have been more pressing that day.
We have some systems that we also have to kind of update
and how we as it pertains to logistics
and maybe service order management to kind of
make that a little bit more electronic than manual. So that's part of the growth
and development opportunities that we have in the department that we
haven't been able to take advantage of.
And again, you mentioned earlier about the vehicles. Some of the vehicles
in our fleet are as old as minimum
ten years old. And the average life of a garbage truck
should be around five to seven years. You should be replacing them.
So we've got to get that vehicle replacement program
up to where it should be so that once we know that five
to seven year mark is there, we're looking at trying to replace that.
Because believe it or not, you're spending more money on maintaining
that vehicle than the vehicle is now worth. So when
those vehicles break down, if the manufacturers and you've
got your three models or four models in now, you've got to wait
on a part to be fabricated in order to get that vehicle fixed,
which means it has to sit and wait for a couple of weeks longer.
And all of that when you don't have, again, two greatest assets the absence
of employees, the absence of equipment. You're going to experience those
delays in services. So the
model that the team has generated that seems to be effective right now.
They're always going to concentrate on garbage first.
We don't want that to sit out for days and whatnot and
draw the flies and vectors that come along with that. And then we'll
make up the recycling a little bit later during the week. So just
a snapshot of the delay. And what I've stated to your predecessor,
Director Hayes, when he brought this to my attention years ago, that we were needing
a garbage fee because all these other major cities in the state of Texas have
a monthly garbage fee.
What I stated as when I was president of my civic club and president of
the super neighborhood. And I've asked and mentioned this to
civic clubs when I go out and they start talking about
missed pickups and what have you regarding trash is
that if there is a garbage fee, in my opinion,
I'm hoping it's not just to pick up your trash
can and your recycling bid. It's also going to be to pick
up those tires that are being dumped on the
vacant lot. It's also to be pick up that illegal dumping, that's being
dumped in the neighborhood, that's bringing down our neighborhood,
that's causing crime because of all this illegal dumping.
So it's a catch 22 and we pay a
monthly garbage fee. Constituents are going to expect more than just picking
up the trash can and your recycling bin. And that's what
I'm hoping will happen is that we'll be able to pick up those tires while
I'm able to pick up the illegal dumping and clean up our neighborhoods at the
same time. And I think the majority of the public will go
with it. Exactly. Just to add
on to that, again, there are some opportunities to create
some more programs that concentrate on solid waste. And I
know we have code enforcement officers and we work with our neighborhood department
with that. But in order to address the issues that we
have now, I really feel that there would be some benefits for the solid waste
department to have its own code enforcement team,
maybe two or three for each sector. And as we see these illegal
dumping issues pop up, it gives us an opportunity to concentrate the
time that's needed on mitigating the issues. And I know you brought that up
to me when we met. And I totally agree that there needs to
be code enforcement inspectors inside of waste so that
those that end up putting their illegal dumping out a day or
two after it was already picked up in the neighborhood, they can be told you're
not supposed to do this. Give them a warning and hopefully they will
stop doing that in that way of cleaning up our neighborhoods.
Council Member David Robinson. Thank you, chair Director, thanks very
much for all the reasons colleagues have said. I wanted to pick up
not only on points made about the requisite
collaboration that you have to do with other departments, whether that's the dawn
in the case of potential generation
of electricity that the Chair asked you about,
we know that's real. We witnessed it ourselves.
Mayor Pro TEM on our recent trip to Denmark,
which is where we were escorted with the delegation, was really
about the Public Works Department. And that's where
the importance of your collaboration, Director, with those who
have maybe more infrastructure dollars in their departments
already. Or ways in which we can bridge the gap between
our solid waste management concerns and how we
might actually embrace how your
part of our annual budget becomes part of our
generation of electricity and our utility structure
and part of what we're doing with the overall maintenance and management of
our resources. And I know that's
not news to you with your experience in Tampa. It's something I mean,
you did throw out the billion dollar figure for
a plant. And I'd like to observe that
that is a really fungible number that's not set
at one point. Repeating billion, that's scalable
in a lot of different directions. How you do it, what you do with
the money, is entirely subject to
how we might devise or design a program.
And so in your six months here, I know you've already brought
a lot of innovation to the department. And I'm so
pleased to see it and witness the work you're doing. I want
to encourage you to continue to work with the Office of Innovation in
the Mayor's department as well as the Sustainable Office.
And that's really my comment. If you have anything to add
to that, I'd love to hear it. Thank you. Council Member Robinson
I don't want that billion dollars to scare you, right? It's a big number.
But you got to look at the value of that beyond
the dollars and cents. So that's land
that you're not taking up that could probably be
used for housing or some sort of future development or just
preservation or whatever the case may be. And then the amount
of revenue that you generate from the sale of energy,
which you have to be careful of nowadays because you have other forms
of energy that are now competitive on the market, CNG and whatnot
you have to watch that, but it does go towards offsetting that expense.
And just to give you a quick story of my level of ignorance,
when I was appointed to be Director in Tampa, the first thing I wanted to
do was sell the waste energy plant because it cost us
10 million to run and we only got 5 million in return.
I'm like, this doesn't make sense. But then I thought about it.
Where are we going to go? Our trucks are going to have to drive 60
miles now just to go to one landfill. So the value of
having that waste energy plant there was
more than just the dollars and cents. Appreciate that very much.
Council Member Abby Cayman Director
normally I ask a question, the question everyone's heard
it already about the needs of the department looking forward, but I think you've covered
a lot of those in terms of looking ahead at the future
and what we need. Is there anything you want to add to
that that has not been discussed? I'm glad you asked.
No, but we did. We covered a lot of it.
As far as any sort of unmet needs as it
relates to that. You heard me talk about vehicle
coordination. That really involves having someone in our
department that just focuses on nothing but vehicles.
And they maintain this outstanding relationship with fleet
maintenance. They hold us accountable, make sure that we're taking care of
the equipment and then they also work with fleet maintenance to make sure vehicles
are available. You heard me speak often about code enforcement officers
as well, a necessary part, additional drivers.
Right now, probably one of the most startling things that I've seen
is I go out on route run into,
believe it's Daniel Williams at the Southeast Service Center.
And he's picking up and I asked him how many homes does he
have on his route and he tells me 3000. I said he's exaggerating.
I get back to the service center to know he's telling the truth.
And that's an example of the department continuously
trying its quest to want to serve our public
and provide that service and giving us everything we
got. But I can tell you 3000 homes for one driver
is unrealistic. The truck will be throwing in the towel at that point in time.
They said they can't do it. We end up overworking the driver in the truck
and we end up in a bad situation.
Again, I definitely want to continue to focus on the illegal dumping this
here. I want to see if we can start dropping some more cameras throughout
the city in some of those areas that have a lot of that unnecessary activity,
see if we can curb some of that behavior. Public Works has been
great to work with as well. We're going to find some of the roads
that are less traveled, like what we had on the news the other day,
and see if we can just block some of the ingress and egress off to
curb that behavior. Well, again, I appreciate it and like
you said, one team or one person
having to deal with 3000 homes,
we shouldn't be asking any city employee to
deal with that. So, thanks. My gratitude again. And also I know
you've really put your head to the ground trying to figure
out some new and unique ways of recruiting and job training.
So I just appreciate the leadership
you and your team are providing. Thank you.
Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, Chair.
What are our annual tipping fees? I believe we
hover around 25 $26
per ton. And on
the recycling revenue?
The recycling fund performance measures, it has 12%
curbside recycling. What exactly does that mean? What is that figure?
It's on the performance measures in the budget book. It says curbside
recycling rate, single stream, 12% target.
I'm not familiar. I have to look that up. You're saying it's in the budget
book? Roman numeral
ten, 164. Okay. There's some targets.
It's the same target as last year. I just don't know what that means.
What's that? 12%. Okay, thank you. And you mentioned 15%
critical vacancies in numbers. I'm curious
on how many drivers you're down. About 55
right now. 55? 55 drivers.
Okay. What other critical positions are
vacant? Those are going to be the critical. Those are critical. Okay, so when you
talk critical vacancies, you're talking about drivers. Yeah, we're talking about drivers.
And you're in the works of bringing those
entry level salaries up? Absolutely. Mayor Turner and
I have been working together and he's
authorized a 6% increase. And now when we go
out, we're also increasing the number of job fairs that we're attending working
with our HR department, jane Cheeks and her team. Okay,
great. And thank you for your help on composting. I noticed it on your accomplishments,
the composting drop off. And thank you for working with the Office of Innovation
and my team on what might come next. I agree with Council Member Gallegos.
I think that the fee is going to have to come with some extras.
And I think if we do go to curbside recycling like other
cities, it would be a voluntary program and an additional fee on the people who
want to participate. And you'd be surprised how many want to participate.
Denver has started this and there's thousands and thousands.
But I can't put anything more on the solid waste
department. We're trying to get less trash so we
can save more of that $25 per ton in shipping
fees. Absolutely. Thank you. Council member Tasha Jackson. Thank you.
And thank you, director, and your team. I just wanted to commend you
guys on a great job that you're doing. Just working with you,
our hot team. Of course I have the hot team. And you had a
conversation about that. I was hoping we can pull them out, but we
can't. So we can use our dollars somewhere else. But you
can see the difference. You can see the neighborhood is a little bit
cleaned, a little bit better, but we need more work and
I know we need more money. And so I just want you to know I
support the fee if you guys
approach that. Approach that because I know we need dollars to move the follow waste
department together forward. But I just want to say congratulations and thank you
for everything that you're doing. Thank you. If I can just add to that,
and I've heard Mayor Turner mention it as well,
another part of success, even though it doesn't involve this, is the funding,
ARPA funding and some of the grant funding that we're able to take advantage of.
I would really like to position the department so that when that funding
goes away, we can continue to maintain some of these programs
that we're able to embark upon right now. And I did ask my
question, the anti litter campaign. So would that continue?
Because that's been a big help. Yes, we are actually in the process of
evaluating bids on that right now. Okay. So that will continue,
and you should not experience a gap in that. That's been the help. So thank
you so much for keeping that council member, Robert Gallegos.
Thank you for Tim. And again, thank you, Director, for everything. You're doing an
outstanding job. I know you're new here and you're getting all these headaches,
but you're doing a great job. So thank you. I just also want
to mention that if we do go with the possibly in the
near future, in the future, a fee that
also, hopefully we follow. I understand Director Hayes had mentioned
the San Antonio model where they have a large trash can.
They have a small trash can, and it depends on the homeowner.
If they have quite a bit of trash, then they'll be paying for
a large trash can, whatever that monthly
fee is. If they have a small trash can, then they'll be paying
a little less than what that normal fee is.
So hopefully that's another model that we can follow also,
and that also encourages people to put more recycling stuff into
your recycling bin, so that way you'll have a smaller trash can and pay
less on your fee. So I'm hoping that's something that
we can look at as well. I'm with you 100%.
I can't even speak. You're talking just as much trash as I am right now.
So there are no other council members in queue. I'll ask my last question a
couple of years ago. This is probably six years ago.
As you well know, many areas of the city have private trash
collection, and we pay them $6 a month per household
for them to get their private collection. We looked at
eliminating that, and we discovered that eliminating that
would cost us a ton of money more, mainly because
we don't have the workforce and we don't have the trucks. So we kept that
intact. So when you talk about garbage fee, I know
it would have to be across the board, so everyone in the city
of Houston would have to be a part of it. So let's say if you
have 500,000 households
and it was $72 a year, $6 a month
times twelve months, that would equate to probably around $34 million
that we could use on something like that. But my question to you, I'm not
sure what you had in Tampa or your other experience.
How difficult is it to get folks that are on private collection where
we really in order for us to pick it up, it would cost
us probably three or four times the $6 a month.
Right. How do we put the genie back in the bottle? In that case,
I think we offer a rate that is just as competitive as
the private company that is providing that current level of service.
I think although we pay $6 a month, I believe that
those residents are actually paying a little bit more to the company.
We just have to make sure that we cover our cost of service. And normally
with municipalities, that rate is a little bit lower than
our private counterparts. They are there to turn a profit.
We're there for reliability. So if we cover our cost
of service, we should be just as competitive. However,
we're to the position right now, like you mentioned earlier, we can't take on any
additional service right now. So the key to doing that
is to crawl before we walk. Yeah.
Great. Thank you. And before I leave, another great employee,
fairly new Veronica, doing a great job for us. So thank you. I'll pass that
along. Council Member Sally Alcorn. Thank you, chair. And just to jump in,
I just want to be clear. If you have private trash right now, you're already
paying a fee for your private trash. You would not be paying the city's
trash fee. It would be like clear, like water authority,
people not paying the drainage. Calm down. I didn't say that. I know exactly
what we pay. We get $6 a month,
$72 a year. And we pay waste management or
a trash collection in addition to it. So my question is
if we talk about a garbage fee and it goes citywide, there is no way
on God's green earth these guys will be able to pick it up right away.
No way. Yeah. So you'd keep your private trust. Yeah. And all
you hear me talk about building it up. Right. Building those reserves. The first
priority should be reducing our dependency on the general fund.
That means we're able to stand on our own. Once we do that,
we don't take on any additional service until we can cover the costs.
That means that we have the employees and equipment to provide that service. Exactly.
So you have to have a build up, take you a year to buy equipment
and employees. And from what we're experiencing right now, we can't get drivers.
Right. So how are you going to get drivers to do citywide?
Mayor Turner. And I got a plan. We're going to turn that around. You got
a plan? I like that. Well, thank you. Appreciate it.
Thanks for your time. Thank you. We have a 1234
public speakers. We'll start it out with Mr. Jason Oliver.
Star six to unmute.
First, I'm concerned about driver safety.
I know that solid waste has been doing a lot with very
little and it seems like even less this year in the
budget we're looking at. Council member Cayman talked about early days
and late nights with people working six days a week. I recall reading an article
about a driver fainting and we're approaching the summer,
how are we taking care of driver safety and are we making improvements
there? And then a second question to follow up on something Council Member
Pollard said, because I want to make sure I know who to direct my comments
to. Directors report. He said Directors report to the
mayor and they were directed to leave. It sounds like you're telling us that it's
not city council, but the mayor who directed city staff not to respond
to our questions. So I just want to make sure should we be directing our
concerns about this policy to council or to the mayor?
You can direct your questions to council if
you have a direct question for council, if you have a
question that is specific to a director, you can
submit those to your council office and we would send those
to the director to get a response for you.
Right, but the policy change that was made
around budget workshops that we hadn't had in previous years, I'm trying to
figure out how we get that back. Yes,
council Member Cayman jason, just to be clear,
I said this before, I'm not chair of BFA,
so I can't speak for that. But what I do know as a chair of
a committee is there is always, including at public safety
been a standing
procedural rule where questions are taken from the
public, submitted to the departments and then responded
to. My understanding is also in terms of time,
things like that. We've already been here and I was going
to thank Saba and others for sitting here all day.
I understand the commitment. All I'm explaining is
this wasn't a rule change. The chair even
indicated that we messed up the first
go round. It has always been in our committees
that questions are submitted from the public, they're submitted
to the departments for a response. For example, my staff takes
all questions from public safety comments,
submits them to department and then emails them back. So I just wanted again,
I'm not telling you which way to feel about it, but I wanted to
speak up for the chair in terms of other committees,
that has been the standard process as well.
Right, but not for the budget workshops. We've been here in
previous years. So I just want to be clear about like, that's not general
practice and it hasn't been standard practice in previous years.
The recordings show it.
I've been sitting here for nine years doing this, so I
think I know a little bit about it. But anyway, I appreciate
your comments. Jason, good to have you here this week.
Jill Grochell,
star six to unmute. Jill saba
Blanding. If Jill's in, we'll come back to you.
I had a couple of questions, but I believe what Jason speaking
to is the fact that last year we were able to
direct our questions to the department heads during the budget workshops.
I don't know if that was a change because it was virtual, but we definitely
had the opportunity last year, so I can't speak to
prior years. Thank you. We did a lot of
different things during COVID when everyone was virtual.
So maybe we just need to go back to everything being virtual.
I'm not a big fan of that, but you're right, we did a lot of
different things last year in a virtual environment
because of that. Yeah, it was really nice and I
appreciated it as a constituent, I don't disagree.
In past workshops, we've been told that we start every day behind based
on low budget for staffing. And so in regards to trash, where are
we in terms of the routes we have versus the routes we need based on
population growth? I believe there's a little bit of an addressing
routes, but just some more details there. And then actually,
several council members address this.
Do you mind if I ask a quick question? Go ahead. Okay, so we've been
told in the past that solid waste needs somewhere around 40 million for additional personnel
and equipment to get up to basic adequate level of service. Okay,
so just updates on that need for the immediate future.
Council Member Alcorn and Pollard, you both brought up the
discussion of fees for solid waste. I'm just curious how this could be
applied equitably so that every Houstonian has access to trash collection and
recycling because illegal dumping
is already an issue. And so just everyone having access to trash and
then, yeah, that's it.
Council Member Pollard so I think we have to really
strategically look at how we put forth the fee. What does that
fee get you? How is it equal across the board, especially when it comes
to those who may have resources and those who
may not. So that's a discussion that we need to have
before I think we do anything with the fee. I think we really need to
educate the voters and the constituents on
what's done in other cities. What can be expected here in this city?
What are the pros? Maybe some of the cons and some of the realistic expectations,
but it is a conversation that we need to have and we really
need to be able to hear your voice on that when we bring forth
what the possibilities are.
But we are the only city, major city in the state of Texas
and maybe even in the US. That does not have that fee. And so
we have to find ways in which, if we do pay a fee,
all communities get a benefit and see a benefit beyond
just normal trash, but also looking into the
uniqueness of each area, whether it's illegal dumping or
whatever, to address those needs as well.
So I'll give you my personal deal. I get my trash
picked up by a contractor. I'm one of the folks that we
get $6 a month from the city not to pick up our
trash. That goes to our homeowners association, who in turn
pays for the private trash collection. We have what's
called back door driveway trash collection.
So they go down the street and they roll up to your driveway and empty
your can and dump it into a bigger can. Then the truck comes
behind it, and we get that two days a week. Ours comes Tuesday, Friday.
We have recycles pick up every Thursday.
So we are very happy with our
trash collection. So if we do go to our garbage fee and
we have to change it, we better do equal or
better, or I will get more complaints,
more complaints under the sun than I care to deal with.
But one of the things that we had an
issue with five, six years ago I forgot when it
was, was when we started looking at the elimination of private
trash collection. We realized we didn't have the people and we didn't have the equipment
to do it. So I'm not sure what Sally Alcorn
has to say over there, but we love our private trash collection,
and we pay for it, and we're glad to pay for it. So if
I have to sit here and vote for a garbage fee, and I argued with
Harry Hayes for years about it, it's going to be tough
for me to do that, because what we
have works extremely well.
All of the cities that I mentioned earlier on all of the cities
that have the fee, you can opt out of the fee and keep your
private trash. Nobody's going to make anybody who has private trash
get city trash. Can I quote you on that, Mayor? Mayor Al
Corn because there's only one person that can state that, and he's up one
floor. Well, a fee that I would support
would not require people to give up their private
trash. Let's quote let's run that tape back, broderick.
Mr. Butler. Stop it. You got any additional
yeah. And I appreciate Council Member Pollard address this I'm not
worried about the constituents that can't afford the fee. I'm worried about those where,
like, every dollar is in
them being able to access trash and recycling, because we don't want
to see that go there. Okay, thank you. Thank you. I will
not be here tomorrow, so thanks for coming for every meeting.
Thank you. Stick around. I'll talk
to you a little bit. Broad Butler, Northeast Houston,
Myrtle Beach, South Carolina does
an excellent job of eliminating illegal dumping. I wish
you would take a look at their plan. It went all the way to the
state level. They have an agreement between the city and
the state to deal with illegal dumping.
But my comments are I want to apologize for losing my composure
earlier. I respect the decision. I didn't expect you to reverse
it. But to sit here and be told.
That well compensated, educated and seasoned directors are
being shielded from. Speaking to the public is frustrating.
But I apologize to the entire council for letting my passions
get the better of me. I'd like to acknowledge the
solid waste department on our side of town in Northeast Houston.
Alice Coffey, Richard Wynn, and Desmond Allen are
names that all Northeast residents know. They have worked
harder. When they have failed, they have stepped up.
And everything that the director told you
about, we already know as citizens because we have a communication
and a dialogue with their staff. So outside
of that, I wish every city department would resemble the solid
waste staff department. And again, Myrtle Beach,
South Carolina. So do you know anything about what they do? Because we
talk about yeah, I read the whole plan one
night when I was running for city council. Would you run
against I have no idea. But they were victorious,
and we're going to go with it because in my eyes today,
they stood 10ft tall. And I'll say that again, so I'm very proud
of them. Myrtle Beach, South Carolina. All I did one night, I said,
everybody's got a thought on this. And then I just went to the Google machine
and I said, give me the best solution for illegal dumping.
It said, Myrtle Beach, South Carolina. Their economy
depends on tourism. For people to come to
this wonderful clear beach in South Carolina.
But they had an economic downturn and all this
trash showed up. Nobody wanted tourists to come and
see a filthy city. They were going to lose millions of dollars.
They came up with a garbage fee. It was $3.
Ended up being $11. The fee was
specific to hire only a team
along with their solid waste department. But that team
only went out and removed illegal dumping. I thought it
didn't make a lot of sense, but as I talked to residents here, they didn't
care how it worked. They just want the trash gone. So Myrtle
Beach created a standalone hot team.
That's all they did. They went throughout the entire city and
removed trash, and it worked very well.
Then the city went to the legislature and
asked them to increase the fines for people who did illegal
dumping. So they had to buy in from the state,
the county, and the state legislature. Sorry,
the city, the county, and the state legislature. So that if you
did dump in Myrtle Beach, South Carolina, you were going to do jail
time and you were going to lose a whole lot of money. And so
now Myrtle Beach is again, they have one of the best responses
to the issue, which is basically, you come here,
you dump, you will either go to jail or you
will be fined into the Stone Age.
And it has worked well for them. I'm looking it up right now, and it's
interesting. A lot of our issues emanates
from the state of texas. And the reason why I say that is we
have a problem not with illegal dumping, but with sand mining operations. And we
discovered that it was less expensive for them to keep illegally
sending sand into our tributaries than it is to remediate it.
So they kept doing it and they kept paying the fines and they paid them
gladly. But you won't solve that problem until you raise the fines
high enough to where it actually hurts them. And it sounds like reading
on Myrtle Beach that's exactly what they did through the state.
And they got the buy in so that they weren't a standalone island trying
to solve a problem that other cities were eventually going to have
in South Carolina. Right. Well, I'll finish reading it, but your other comment
no need to apologize. I appreciate your
vigor and vitality. I think I'm somewhat
like that. Well, but reason people should be able
to have a discourse because at the end of the day, some of
these directors, they don't deal with apparati, they deal
with people's lives. So it kind of matters to us
that we're the lives they might be dealing with one day.
Thank you. We appreciate the efforts of the council
and thank you for your time. You got it. Thank you.
Before we adjourn, please note budget workshops will continue this week
through Thursday, May 19. Our next budget presentation will be special called
BFA committee meeting tomorrow, Thursday the 19th at 09:00
A.m.. I will be out.
I will be in Austin, Texas as my son Michael is graduating
tomorrow at 11:00 a.m.
Hookham. Hookham. So Julie and
I will be there and my daughter will be there for the next couple of
days. Participate in the festivities of the University
city of Texas.
Hookum. We got it. Meet and adjourn. Have a blessed day.
Have a great evening. Come to Clear Lake and come see us.
Sally Alcorn.